but joining me now is Andrew Tate his
videos have been viewed billions of
Times online but he's been banned from
pretty much every mainstream social
media platform including Twitter uh
Andrew say welcome back to Piers Morgan
uncensored um your take on this I think
it's quite interesting because you've
been a victim of being a victims the
right word but you've been removed from
social media platforms for your opinions
um Elon Musk has dedicated himself he
says to restoring Free Speech uh do you
think that's going to include you for
example
I don't think it matters if it includes
me or not I think what's important is
that free speech is the number one
weapon against absolute tyranny and
although you cannot have complete Free
Speech because then conversations
completely break down into asinine
insult fests I do like the idea of The
Changing of the Guard when it comes to
control over information is it possible
Andrew Tate to actually police
something like Twitter to to be a
platform for genuine Free Speech or is
it so toxic and tribal now that whatever
happens you know before we had all the
people on the right screaming away that
there would be no platformed and so on
now you've got all the people on the
left screaming that they're being no you
know diminished in some way uh it's it's
very tribal very toxic can musk cut
through that and if so how
yeah it's going to be extremely
difficult there's always going to be one
group of people who are extremely
unhappy but I think that anybody who's
perspicacious enough to understand the
truth of what's been going on in the
world recently will know that the left
and their narratives have certainly been
protected for a very long time and the
universe has swings and balances and God
often restores balance to the universe
and perhaps it might swing the other way
for a while I truthfully am a person who
believes that all points of view are
extremely important because as soon as
you block points of view you have
absolute tyranny and in a way it's sort
of self-defeating isn't it because you
carried on getting huge attention it was
interesting to me that when you came on
the show for example we've had I think
nearly six million people have viewed
the whole interview that we did which is
a huge number of people certainly far
higher than Washington conventional
television so you have a whole you have
a whole world out there online which
operates away from social media
platforms
yeah uh I've been very very successful
in spite of them but not many people can
do that
I'm in a pretty unique position but I
think that everybody needs a voice to a
degree and social media platforms are
now the most important platforms on the
planet
they control information and they
influence real world decisions and they
influence people's perception of reality
the last few years of covet have been a
perfect example of what happens when you
censor one side of the argument and you
only allow one point of view to be
purported by the Matrix in and of itself
and that's how you end up in tyrannical
situations I think you were just
discussing that pierce yeah and I think
it's a perfectly valid point you know
people have quite I think quite rightly
held me to task over some of the
positions I took during the covert
pandemic notably when the scientists
said as a definitive fact that you you
couldn't transmit the virus if you had
the vaccine it turned out that wasn't
true and I based my observations on that
supposed fact and said right but in that
case if you refuse to be vaccinated you
shouldn't get the same rights as people
who've been vaccinated if if it's true
that if you're unjabbed you can pass it
on it turned out actually there's not
much difference whether you've been
vested in the law and at that point I
changed my mind
uh but I I felt that there were a lot of
people who were being de-platformed from
Twitter at the time for questioning the
validity of scientific statements and
they would then be a complete U-turn so
I do think it was a very interesting
period actually for testing what Free
Speech it was actually worse than that
you're right Pierce but it was actually
worse than interesting because what
happens is when you censor an entire
side of the argument and only allowed
one side of the argument to have a voice
you are changing reality in real time
you are shaping the world the only
reason that scam continued as long as it
did and the only reason people didn't
get to see their own parents get buried
and the only reason people sat and
masked missed cancer appointments
because they were scared of the common
cold was because they were censoring
anybody who said anything contrary to
the purported version of events that the
mainstream media decided they want the
entire world to swallow it's beyond
simply interesting and it's beyond
simply uh funny or coincidental yeah I
mean I will challenge you on one thing
it's not the common talk right covid-19
has killed 6.6 million people it is one
of the most deadly viruses certainly of
our lifetime so it wasn't the common
cold but I do think it is completely
Justified for people to say we should be
more cautious I think about accepting
during fast-moving pandemics the word of
scientists as being sacrosanct because
on a number of things from the use of
masks to the efficacy of vaccines and
preventing transmission they did massive
u-turns
I've read enough history books to know
that the people who do the censoring are
never the good guys and they've been
censoring a law of arguments for a very
long time in the name of good they are
weaponizing virtue and it's always in
the name of tyranny anybody who is out
here trying to silence an entire side of
an argument on any subject whether it's
covid-19 immigration anything else they
are the evil people who are out for
absolute mind control of the populace I
certainly agree I certainly agree that I
think the healthiest thing for any
democracy is for All Views to be aired
and debated we seem to have lost the
ability to debate you know when I
interviewed you yeah we had a few
fractious moments but actually I thought
it was a pretty spirited debate between
people who perhaps had you know
preconceived views of each other and
I've got no problem interviewing you now
about this because I think you have an
interesting take on this stuff
and that's the key to life when you
reach that level of adolescence in your
mindset where you can't handle any point
of view that is contrary to your own
then you're truly a broken person and
that's what the internet is purporting
it's very interesting you said about
Twitter being tribal there's a large
contingent of people on Twitter who
simply cannot handle reading and opinion
which differs from their own and that is
a degree of immaturity that we do not
need adults to be functioning with in
the modern world no I agree if you're
Elon Musk this idea of charging eight
dollars now a month uh whatever it is to
access the Blue Tick premium Twitter
account would you do that would you pay
the extra
I think that social media companies for
a very long time have lived in an
absolute fantasy where they've printed
money from thin air by charging people
for pixels and they grew into these
large conglomerates with too many staffs
sitting around doing nothing having
coffee breaks and Elon Musk is a
businessman he's walked into the office
and he's firing a bunch of people who
are messing around doing nothing and he
wants his business to make money as it
absolutely should and how he decides
that happens is his prerogative I don't
see why we should sit and accept that
our website needs 200 000 people sitting
around discussing in Long meetings
sitting on bean bags about policy of
human rights of some garbage when he's
come along and said no I'm a businessman
we're going to charge for our service
we're going to reduce the number of
Staff we're going to be a functional
coherent company as they should be and
that's his prerogative to do it as he's
bought the company I think he can do
whatever he wants yeah I mean I don't
disagree because I remember the
appalling censorship of the New York
Post exclusive about Hunter Biden the
son of the presidents about his laptop
this is three weeks before the election
that Joe Biden won he was heading you
know to a possible Victory but it was
tight and that story they reckon could
have tipped it either way but it was
completely suppressed and censored uh
starting with Twitter then Facebook then
others Twitter literally locked out the
New York Post account for two weeks for
breaking a completely true story I
thought that was shameful
it's worse than shameful it's worse than
shameful when you control information
you control the real world they affect
the real world in absolute
in real time they are genuinely
affecting the reality people live in
they are not just a company they're not
just a social media platform it affects
absolutely every single person on the
planet when it changes who is elected I
don't want to comment specifically on
Hunter Biden or the laptop I would never
kill myself but I don't think it's fair
that they would hide certain key
information that close to an election
and the fact that they've done that was
done specifically to affect to affect
the world that we all live in and we all
have to suffer the consequences of those
things so to sit and say that these
companies can just do whatever they want
in their private Etc no free speech is
beyond important for democracy it's
important for the reality that we exist
under
Andrew Tate thank you for joining me I
appreciate it
thank you friend